we just put out our final galaxy sm+
review and since the SNA is very similar
to the sm plus I decided on this video
instead of another similar review so if
you want a good detailed look at both
the good and the bad check that out
after this video ideally we would have
all three phones but since the s10 is so
similar to the sm plus we just went with
a bigger one if something is different
in the real world will point it out
let's start out by talking about the
price going for the SNe saves you
between 150 to 250 dollars and the real
world that may matter a whole lot were
not at all but for most it does
thankfully even though the price is
lower not much has been compromised
looking at these two online the flagship
s10 devices look so much sleeker with
their thinner bezels but unlike the
iPhone 10 are with their bezels look
much bigger in person the s10 II looks
great and they aren't distracting best
10 plus does look sleeker because of the
curved edges but after a few days your
brain just ignores that just like
notches or cutouts one thing you can't
ignore is the feel in your hand and let
me tell you the s10 a feels amazing
better than iPhone 10's the 6 the SE the
oneplus 60 the pixel everything the
frame has a slight curve and the power
and fingerprint button combination is in
the perfect spot with a subtle cutout
and since the phone is smaller it fits
really nicely in the hand thus 10 plus
on the other hand isn't so great at
least in my opinion since both the front
and the back glass are really curved the
frame has to be very slim so you only
have a small area of contact in your
hand not only does it not feel as secure
but I have many accidental missed
touches which never happen on the e
unfortunately I did hit the big speed
button so much more often with a 10 e
since my index finger landed right on
that button one of the biggest Hardware
differences is the fingerprint reader
the S temps have an in display
ultrasonic sensor which is super cool
but in the real world the S 10 ease
standard design is so much faster and
more reliable even after the software
updates and putting my thumbprint in
three times it's still flaky which makes
sense since it's a first generation
feature whereas the S tonie's scanner
has been perfected it's also in the
perfect spots when you grab your phone
you guys should turn it on and scan at
the same time and like you saw it's
basically instant one thing that really
surprised me both from the Samsung
events and using the phone's long term
is how the SNe stacks up
yes the display is lower res but it's
also smaller so the pixel density is
still great it's still the same Ola text
so is better contrast and maximum
brightness than the flagship iPhones but
at the same price point as the iPhone 10
R which has roughly a 720p LCD display
you really don't lose any display
quality going with a 10 e over the 10
plus along with that the speakers are
surprisingly just as good
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
flipping over to the back we have our
camera arrays the s10 and 10 plus also
have a heart rate scanner which is
missing on the s10 II but personally
I've never used it if that's a feature
you care about let us know in the
comment section below the other missing
feature that matters a lot more to me is
the lack of the telephoto lens if you
like to zoom in for shots you'll be
limited to a maximum of 8 X instead of
10 X and the quality is also worse with
that said I think Samsung made the right
choice by ditching the telephoto lens
instead of choosing to ditch the ultra
white now let's jump into screen sizes
unlike Apple who made their 10 our have
the middle screen size and forced you to
pay more for either the 10s or the 10s
plus if you want a smaller phone or a
larger phone Samsung chose to make the
SNe their smallest device I will say
that even though it is also 5.8 inches
just like the 10s the display does seem
slightly larger because of the lack of
the notch at the top if you're an
average phone user or you're upgrading
from a smaller device the estin II will
be perfect but being a power user who
spends a lot of time on my phone it does
seem a bit too small to me personally
having a 6 point 4 inch display is nice
especially for trying to be productive
or even for watching videos or playing
games along with the smaller size we
also have a smaller battery and if
you're a power user you do notice that
day to day the Sun plus lasted me a full
Dave have used whereas the s10 II would
have to be topped off the 6.1 inch size
is probably the perfect middle ground
but if I had to choose between the
standard s10 or the s10 II I'd likely go
for the s tiny and deal with a slightly
smaller size there's just something
about the phone that's really enticing
once you hold it in your hand and use it
it's hard to describe but if you're into
cameras it's kind of like picking up and
using a fuji film it may not be the best
camera at most features but it feels
great and its really enjoyable to use
and that leads me to my overall opinion
if you're an average user the smaller
screen size won't matter as much and
with that the battery life will be more
than enough if you're a power user the
sm+ is likely the better choice because
of the larger display and better battery
life but even then I think many will be
happy with us to name thanks for
watching if you want to see more videos
click that little circle above to
subscribe and check out our detailed
long-term at Sun plus review which most
of it also applies to the SNe this has
been max with max tech and I'll see you
in the next video
[Music]